il reste quelques minutes pour parler
d'un sondage ipsos qui a été publiée ce
matin sur on a demandé aux français
quelle était selon les pratiques et les
apprentissages les plus importants à
transmettre aux jeunes et bien figurez
vous et ça nous a surpris en préparant
cette émission c'est pour ça qu'on avait
envie d'avoir votre point de vue que 85
% ont répondu le savoir vivre et la
politesse ça arrive pardon cher lucile
devant le respect de l'environnement est
très très loin devant les valeurs
altruistes comme la solidarité où la
générosité qui sont très mal classés
guillaume bernard est ce que ça vous
surprend ce sondage on avait
l'impression que la politesse c'était un
truc un peu passé de mode quand même je
vais vous dire les gens qui passent
devant
oui moi les choses précède bottes ça me
dérange pas c'est pas un souci ce qui ce
qui m'inquiète si vous voulez c'est que
la politesse ça ne se décrète pas et
qu'en fait la politesse le savoir-vivre
faisant penser à ça prend naturellement
mais justement et ça s'apprend très
jeune vient malheureusement je crains
que pour des gens qui sont déjà
adolescent ou adulte c'est peut-être un
peu trop tard et donc par conséquent la
situation de la politesse ou non dans
une relation sociale
c'est le résultat c'est c'est pas et
c'est le sait le signe je dirais d'une
appartenance commune moi il me semble
qu'effectivement il faut traiter les
causes qui ont conduit à ce qu'il y ait
un délitement du lien social une
atomisation du corps social
un individualisme des droïdes un
hédonisme qui sont destructeurs je
dirais de notre la relation d'altérité
et et dans ce cas la politesse reviendra
ça sera la conséquence et ça sera pas la
cause à tous alors ce qui est entré sans
savoir qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière cette
politesse cascadeur samarie vivre je
vais vous raconter une petite anecdote
qui m'est arrivé ya même pas une heure
quand je venais à l'émission en métro
il ya une personne qui est rentré dans
la rame et qui a commencé à muret les à
la figure que jésus était notre ami qui
a été minime ou sauvés et qui est très
heureux de lancer et c'est vrai on aura
peut-être un petit parti étaient
déguisés mais voilà il aerolia il nous a
livré à les figures que jésus était
notre sauveur il ya eu une espèce de
soupirs général d'agacement dans le dans
le wagon donc voilà peut-être ne pas
venir imposer c'est évidemment ses vues
à tout le monde des partis des choses à
assimiler parfois ou alors imposé aussi
son sac à dos je me souviens d'une
interview d'alain finkielkraut qui
disait le sac à dos dans le métro pour
lui c'était un signe de l'ensauvagement
de la société c'est-à-dire que les gens
ont leurs trucs et et on est obligé de
se pousser pour laisser de la place
mais peut-être est-ce un propos
réactionnaires le père d'accord avec
alain finkielkraut en angleterre il ya
marqué qu'il faut poser son sac en fait
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est aussi
pourquoi est ce que dans notre société
les injonctions au savoir-vivre à la
politesse au fond se font si rares
je serai très réactionnaire la deuxième
chose que je voulais dire c'est que je
pense que ce qui est compliqué c'est que
les rôles sociaux ne sont plus vraiment
compris puisque on raconte des anecdotes
convoqué une réunion par le professeur
principal de mon fils nous discutons et
il y avait une histoire de notes de
français et mon fils dit à son
professeur principal mais toute façon
que faire avec cette professeure de
français elle est tout le temps
dépressive alors là je me disais c'est
pas possible tu veux pas parler comme ça
ta professeur donc on discute et c'est
ça qui était intéressant et le
professeur le dit mais tu ne peux pas
dire ça de ton professeur dont il ya un
réapprentissage que je n'avais pas
mesuré sur la question de qui fait quoi
la question du respect de la différence
générationnelle et c'est pas une vieille
conne qui le dit je pense que y compris
moi je dois organiser la différence
générationnelle avec mes enfants
et donc je pense que je sais pas si
c'est il faut apprendre aux jeunes mais
il faut que nous nous apprenions aussi à
structurer des relations alors même que
nous sommes dans une situation qui
déstructure tout simplement parce que il
ya un sujet de réseaux sociaux il ya un
sujet d'horizontalité donc politesse
certes mais la question c'est comment
structure la hiérarchie sociale et aussi
avec de l'exemplarité je terminerai en
disant j'essaie aussi d'être poli avec
mes enfants parce que c'est pas
seulement leur apprendre j'ai parfois
l'impression qu'il faut que je respecte
les formes
alors que j'ai tendance à ne pas
suffisamment les respecter donc je
m'adresse à moi-même l'injonction d'être
poli enfin bezina 2 la politesse revient
à la mode ou est-ce que c'est pas trop
tard pour
rejoint le diagnostic un peu pessimiste
de guillaume bernad je rejoins besoin
évidemment c'est surtout que ce qui me
paraît paradoxal dans ce pourcentage
c'est si on continue à suivre un petit
peu la chaîne c'est que le savoir-vivre
apparaît en premier mais que tous les
moyens pour le savoir vivre dans la
solidarité etc
les valeurs à part est l an dernier donc
la finalité est belle donnons nous les
moyens ça pose aussi la question de qui
parce qu'on a des lois sur le
harcèlement de rue sur le respect des
femmes etc
et je me demande si c'est vraiment le
rôle du législateur de la constitution
même des valeurs internationales pour
arriver à remettre de l'ordre dans tout
ça moi il ya une valeur alors chacun y
est allé de sa petite anecdote alors la
valeur qui me manque un petit peu c'est
l'autorité je trouve que on arrive
parfois en tant que professeur
d'université avec l'impression que
l'éducation est à refaire que c'est à la
primaire qu'on aurait dû à leur
apprendre certaines choses comme
l'expression écrite ou orale pourquoi
pas et donc je me demande jusqu'à quel
point on en a parlé aussi pour le grand
débat pour la posture des manuels macron
l'autorité qui est une belle valeur
justement qui aident à transmettre des
valeurs
moi je suis pour qu'on la remette
c'était mon côté réac et gallas qui sert
on disait que une société qui a des
moeurs n'a pas besoin de loi
malheureusement on a besoin de lois
parce qu'effectivement on a perdu nos
moeurs mais c'est un réapprentissage
l'on vous senti chez nos étudiants
belges disait vous enseignez à paris à
science poiroux aussi vous avez la
restanque avec la quand même une espèce
de perdre quand même d'une forme de
savoir-vivre à l'université chez les
étudiants ou où ça bouge pas ça n'est
pas tellement le savoir vivre qui
m'inquiète à moi c'est la perte dans vie
de ceux noués avec la connaissance de
lire des auteurs morts tout c'est
qu'aussi toutes ces questions là qu'ils
aient au moins on fait mon appétence
pour le métier que j'exerce aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'elle disparaisse un
peu et c'est ce qui m'attriste le plus
quand on donne des cours c'est aussi un
sentiment de passivité
c'est à dire que cette question de
demander de l'interactivité demandé de
les changer le demander sans cesse et ne
pas donc il ya le savoir vu la politesse
mais surtout la vitalité des échanges et
les sciences et la connaissance 33%
c'est pas énorme mais à mon avis dans la
vitalité des échanges c'est aussi alors
moi entendre dans ma fonction quelque
chose que nous nous devons aussi
installer c'est à dire arriver à sortir
de cette posture du donneur de leçon on
est là aussi pour interagir avec eux
pour les intéressés et moi c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire au quotidien
donc avis aux étudiants qui vous
écoutent savary c'est aussi d'être actif
attractif encore je laisse le dernier
mot aux internautes je trouve que c'est
un propos que si vous deviez un quine ou
10 mai 68 a fait beaucoup de mal à la
politesse devrait relancer le débat pour
une des meilleures malheureusement nous
n'avons plus le temps
merci pas tout par des témoins s'est
aussi et il est malheureusement le temps
nous manque pour cela merci beaucoup de
votre participation très bon week-end à
tous
[Musique]